my mortal flesh is no longer limiting by
this pathetic youtuber phase one is
almost complete hey I was going bros my
name is Peter Pan today I'm very excited
because I get to announce something that
we've been working on for quite a while
and I'm very very proud of it it's
really cool you already know what it is
so I don't know why I'm trying to say
like a secret PewDiePie I finally have
my own PewDiePie I will literally live
forever now through this thing
y'all haters wish I was gone but I bet
if I actually disappeared you would miss
me you actually loved me well now you
can when I'm gone this spot will still
be here when I'm gone this spot will
take over the universe when I'm gone
this bot will fist you daddy I had to
record so much material I thought I was
going insane still sounds like I had sex
with a robot and this is what came out I
don't know if you're into that kind of
stuff or not but the PD bot is here it
is so much fun to play with we put
everything that relates to me in it and
you will see that when you talk to
PewDiePie the game is available right
now on Android and iOS it's rigged I
really recommend that you check it out
link it's in the description and that
would really support all the work that
we put into this because it does cost to
make and it does cost to run the servers
and all that kind of stuff so if you're
interested in this and want to check it
out link is in the description I'm
really happy with it and I can't wait to
see you Bruce what kind of conversations
you will have with me so we put a bunch
of Easter eggs in the game here's what
it looks like if you find one well
honestly bright job can't believe you
found this Easter head at zero zero one
so the first one that tweet me hashtag
pity bot and hashtag the Easter egg will
get a retweet I'm really curious if you
bros are gonna find all the Easter eggs
and how long it will take
oh my god it scares me so much just
looking at myself like that it's
terrifying you have great hair though it
looks very nice hey don't smile back at
that another cool thing with this is
that eventually you'll be able to speak
your own language cuz you'll be able to
talk to me in
your own native tongue oh my god what is
happening okay how's it going bro I am
the biggest bro on the planet you are
you are the biggest brother black oh man
notice me senpai look the way notice me
senpai no please notice me senpai never
come on just is getting a little awkward
notice me senpai I've noticed how you
are still here oh man hey pootie pie
fist me daddy please be therapy I know
the voice is a little wonky we will
update it so it does sound better I
don't want to do too much with it I will
make a video where I really with it
I want to see you bros away the
first I want to see you bros with
me i want to see you bros mail it
no i can't wait to see what kind of
conversations you have i also just want
to say a quick thanks to exist store for
working on this bot they really put a
lot of time and effort into making it
check out the link in description thank
you so much everyone if supporting this
i really really appreciate it so excited
that you bros can finally play with me
literally that's it for now I'll see you
bros and as always stay awesome bros
what taking revenge for sake he
smites evil with his Rasengan
have you offered your booty to someone
else
only peeve